[Música]
el cuerpo se transforma en una prisión
el pasado el presente y el futuro
existen como una fuerza única una
oscilación sin gravedad se cierne a una
altura Espeluznante los contornos de las
personas y las cosas se disuelven
numerosos poetas y escritores han
intentado describir la experiencia del
ataque de pánico una sensación tan
abrumadora que mucha gente la confunde
con un infarto un acb u otra crisis
posiblemente fatal si bien el ataque de
pánico no provoca heridas físicas
perdurables el miedo a tener otro ataque
puede limitar el día a día de una
persona y causar más ataques de pánico
hay estudios que indican que casi un
tercio de nosotros experimentará un
ataque de pánico al menos una vez en la
vida ya sea su primer ataque o el
centésimo o que esté presenciando el
ataque de otra persona todos preferirían
la experiencia incluso aprender al
respecto puede resultar incómodo pero es
necesario Pues el primer paso para
prevenir los ataques de pánico es
entenderlos un ataque de pánico es una
reacción exagerada a la respuesta
fisiológica normal del organismo ante la
percepción de peligro esta respuesta
comienza en la amígdala la región
cerebral que procesa el miedo cuando la
amígdala percibe peligro estimula el
sistema nervioso simpático el cual
desencadena la liberación de Adrenalina
la adrenalina aumenta el pulso cardíaco
y la respiración para que la sangre y el
oxígeno lleguen a los músculos de brazos
y piernas también se envía más oxígeno
al cerebro para volverlo más alerta y
ágil
durante un ataque de pánico esta
respuesta se exacerba Más allá de lo que
sería útil en una situación de peligro
esto produce un pulso cardíaco acelerado
respiración dificultosa o
hiperventilación los cambios en el
torrente sanguíneo producen mareos y
entumecimiento en manos y el momento más
intenso de un ataque de pánico es a los
10 minutos cuando la corteza prefrontal
releva a la amígdala y estimula el
sistema nervioso parasimpático esto
desencadena la liberación de la hormona
acetilcolina que disminuye el ritmo
cardíaco y pone fin al ataque de pánico
en un ataque de pánico la percepción de
peligro del organismo es suficiente para
desencadenar la respuesta que tendríamos
ante una amenaza real no sabemos
exactamente Por qué sucede esto pero a
veces algunos indicios del entorno nos
recuerdan una experiencia traumática del
pasado que puede causarlo el ataque de
pánico puede ser parte de los trastornos
de la ansiedad como el estrés
postraumático el Toc y el trastorno de
ansiedad generalizada los ataques
recurrentes las preocupaciones por
nuevos ataques y los cambios de
comportamiento para evitarlos pueden
Conducir a un diagnóstico de trastorno
de pánico los principales tratamientos
para el trastorno de pánico son los
antidepresivos y la terapia cognitivo
conductual ambos tienen una tasa de
respuesta de alrededor del 40% Aunque un
paciente que responde a uno podría no
responder al otro los antidepresivos
producen efectos secundarios y el 50% de
los pacientes sufre recaídas cuando deja
de tomarlos la terapia tiene una tasa de
recaída del 20%
el objetivo de la terapia en el caso de
estos pacientes es ayudarlos a aprender
y activar mecanismos para ejercer
control físico y mental sobre las
sensaciones y los pensamientos asociados
al ataque de pánico la terapia Inicia
con la explicación de las causas
fisiológicas del ataque de pánico e
incluye ejercicios musculares y de
respiración para ayudar a controlar de
forma consciente los patrones de
respiración luego se enseña la
reestructuración cognitiva que implica
Identificar y cambiar los pensamientos
comunes durante un ataque pensar que se
cortará la respiración que tendrá un
infarto o que morirá y reemplazarlos por
pensamientos más realistas el siguiente
paso es la exposición a las sensaciones
corporales y a las situaciones que
comúnmente desencadenarían un ataque de
pánico el propósito Es cambiar la
creencia a través de la experiencia de
que estas sensaciones y situaciones son
peligrosas incluso tras la terapia no es
sencillo esto Al momento de un ataque
pero con práctica estas estrategias
pueden prevenirlos aminorarlos y reducir
El dominio que ejerce el pánico sobre la
vida de una persona
más allá de las terapias formales Muchos
pacientes se encuentran alivio en la
misma creencia que la terapia Busca
inculcar el miedo no puede lastimarte
pero aferrarse a él aumenta el pánico
Incluso si jamás ha tenido un ataque de
pánico entender de qué se trata lo
ayudará a reconocerlo en usted mismo o
en otras personas y reconocerlo es el
primer paso hacia su prevención
desea saber más sobre Cómo se manifiesta
el estrés en nuestro cuerpo mire este
video y Si desea asegurarse de aprender
algo nuevo cada semana suscríbase
[Música]